as carlos martinez tries to pick up win
number four tonight carlos certainly
wants a do-over after his last start
against the dodgers uh he's had some
very good moments and a lead off walk to
hernandez here's ahmed rosario hits that
ball high in the air deep left center
field long run that's going to be in the
alley that's going to go all the way to
the wall
around third here comes cesar hernandez
relay through all the way to the plate
not in time and going into third base is
rosario and the indians lead it one to
nothing
and ahmed rosario has now hit his fourth
triple here in 2021 nobody out runner at
third and jose ramirez batting
left-handed and a ground ball hit weekly
to first that'll get the run home jose
ramirez is retired it's two to nothing
cleveland rbi number 32 for jose two
down and that'll bring up bobby bradley
hit the
other way into the shift and nolan
arnado for the indians there's cy young
award winner shane bieber makes start
number 13 on the season so far six and
three on the year with an earned run
average of 3.08 two down nobody on paul
goldsmith the pitch swung on ripped
toward the gap in right center on the
run diving zimmer made the catch
oh what a play by bradley zimmer on a
dead sprint and a full layout in right
center so austin with his seventh hit in
his last 15 games has a one out single
here in the second inning and here's
bradley zimmer
first strikeout for carlos martinez and
there's two away carlos looks a little
better this inning he's hitting spots i
would say better with the fastball and
gets the call there from our home plate
um fire chris siegel here comes the uh
o2 pitch now
oh it's a beauty strike three call and
that takes care of the indians here in
the uh second inning four up four down
for shane bieber brings in tyler o'neil
o'neil has 13 home runs to lead the
carters in that department o'neill puts
it sharply in it off the ground
rosario and the criminals have their
first hit and it comes against a
breaking ball here's matt carpenter
eighth pitch of the year that strike
three goal carpenter took a breaking
ball that was right there i don't know
well he got it up there well he's saying
it's high but it can't be high and it
can't be low that was a good take on the
one on the low one but that was a strike
i agree with you and the cardinals have
runner at the corners two down for the
catcher andrew kisner bangs it sharply
to first right at bradley makes the play
unassisted we'll go to the third
runner's head first and third and nobody
out ramirez batting left-handed runner
goes the pitch swung out and hammered
high and deep to right away out of here
gone a majestic moon shot for jose
ramirez
a three-run bomb to right and the
indians leading it five to nothing
ramirez with his 14th home run four rbis
tonight home half of the third cardinals
trailing five nothing swinging him foul
tip hung on to by austin hedges
strikeout number two for shane people
two quick outs and dylan carlson swing
gonna miss striking out with a fastball
in on his hands bieber's third shane
bieber when he gets five or more runs in
support he is 21 and 0. nolan arena was
coming up
and a miss he went fishing and that is
strikeout number four so as you said
they they tend to start becoming bunches
second time around they'll start coming
well the cardinals need to cash in on
this a walk and a hit by pitch with two
outs and mundo sosa is coming
here comes o'neill
throw going into third base cardinals
get on the board a little two out rally
here in the whole map of the fourth and
it's 5-1
bases loaded and all this being done
with two outs and the tying run will
come to the plate john nagowski swung
out ground ball third base dug out by
ramirez the short way to second in time
for the force the cardinals get on the
board but they leave him loaded and
we'll head to the fifth tommy edmond top
of the lineup
took a fastball for a called third
strike that's five k's for bieber and
this is a head scratcher for tommy
edmond goldsmith at first base in two
down now nolan aronado oh for two
tonight he swings and pops it up on the
infield first base side foul territory
bradley makes the call in the catch five
to one drive as we head to the sixth
bieber is at first base with one out
hedges over at third cesar hernandez has
walked singled and scored two runs
tonight
and hernandez shoots one to left get the
job done hedges tags he'll come home to
score and it's now six to cleveland
bottom of the sixth shane bieber had 86
pitches two down and the catcher andrew
kisner
a swing and a pop-up this one is behind
the plate hedges coming near the screen
he's got room he makes the two-handed
grab and bieber's giving the indians six
more superb endings seventh is next so
eddie rosario and his second knock of
the night josh naylor is coming up
fly ball to carlson in center off the
bat at josh naylor
score this heading for daniel ponce de
leon time to stretch
and the tribe goes to brian shaw for the
seventh inning after shane bieber went
six innings allowed one run walked two
struck out five and that ends a streak
of 26 consecutive starts with at least
six strikeouts for shane bieber it's the
fourth
longest streak since 1920 two down
here's dylan carlson
get out of my way um watch him almost
run over the home plate on fire goes up
and get out of my way uh oh you want to
dance see this lap yeah this is why you
couldn't have caught arch because you
would have ran him
the pitch swung on a roller to first and
again bradley with the underhand flip to
shaw covering
and shaw looks terrific and quickly has
a one two three ending it is the bottom
of the eighth and emanuel
make appearance number 27. goldsmith
draws the walk and that'll bring up
nolan aronado
swinging a miss chased away and
aronado's out number one
swing and a miss fastball got him two
out two on here's edmundo sosa swing and
a mess cutter way outside
at 101 miles an hour and sosa
is the third victim to go down swinging
in the eighth and the indians have a
chance to remove all doubt they've got
runners at second and third nobody out
for eddie rosario
right back up the middle and through
that'll get one run home here comes
another yeti rosario with his third hit
of the night he's driven in a pair
and he has effectively put this one away
for the tribe runners at second and
third that's going to bring up bradley
zimmer and the pitch swung in and lined
him to center bradley has a two-run
single
bradley
and naylor will score
and bradley zimmer with a two-run single
to center makes it a four-run inning and
a 10-1 cleveland lead the bottom of the
ninth is next and the cardinals are down
to their final out
swings and
hits a fly ball to center field
book it the indians blast the cardinals
in the series opener by a final score of
10 to one